patrick made his season debut on the
10th in los angeles six earned rundown
six hits over four and a third
two two
and this one out to center
you're gonna have to tag a fly ball to
get it out of this cool place tonight
carson kelly bats second
and he drives this one the other way
deep to right field soto will play it
off the wall and that's over the wall
carson kelly
in the two hole gets his second homerun
in his many games and the diamondbacks
strike first against corbin you try to
punch as many hot hitters together in
your lineup as you possibly can and
carson kelly as i mentioned has been
swinging the hot bat for the diamondback
so get him up at the top of the order
maybe get him an extra at bat in this
ball game and it pays off in his first
at bat with an opposite field home run
now the batter is edward
escobar lifts one deep to left center
roadless on the track and that one's
gone diamondbacks back to back in dc
it's two nothing
edwardo escobar has had the home run
stroke lately
that's five homers in seven games for
eduardo we're more used to seeing
eduardo hit for power from the left side
of the plate but muscles up here as a
right-handed hitter against patrick
corbin and he rides one out to give the
d-backs an early two-nothing lead
they've handed you here right now as far
as druva cabrera
who was part of that big part of that
washington 2019 world championship team
he takes off his helmet and salutes the
crowd as they are up applauding him he
had a nice video tribute before the ball
game
[Applause]
right to harrison at second
out number two and now wyatt mathisson
will band with two on and two out and
two in
base hit
and they're going to wave nick ahmed
around the our big eye single for wyatt
matheson and the diamondbacks put up
three in the first against corbin it's
merrill kelly nine earned runs allowed
in ten innings over his first two starts
losses to the padres and the rockies
looking to get that turned around here
today
what a play by eduardo escobar and is he
all right
rolling around on his shoulder just a
bit
so here's josh bell one for six so far
and the first pitch to him is head of
the year to left field young started in
now going back it's gonna be over his
head one hop and bounces over the wall
and out of play for an automatic double
soto will come in to score
and bell into second has his first rbi
and it's now arizona three in washington
one
and another good changeup gets the out
of schwarberg two down to the first
brings up josh harrison
bring up josh harrison
this one over his head heading for the
turf in right field and it's a one-run
game as josh harrison is now seven for
12. so starlin castro the batter
castro to right center
did he get enough
see
you
later
just enough and just like that
the nationals have the lead with two out
of the bottom of the first inning bang
zoom goes castro
it's the nationals four the diamondbacks
three
bases are full of diamondbacks with no
outs in the second
0-2
is that a swing and a miss it is
[Applause]
one out
that's poked off harrison at second base
he's got no playing we're tied at four
[Applause]
haven smith two played appearances two
walks
and that one gets the diamond backs the
lead
wasn't quite getting the swings and
misses with a slider last year felt he
needed another pitch and now he hits
matheson and that force is in a run and
the bases stay loaded and the dime
evacuated six to four
well keep it going
young drives one the other way soto
backing up andrew young and it's in the
bullpen for a grand slam
andrew young
10-4 diamondbacks just didn't get it out
there where he wanted it on the corner
up a little bit and
andrew young showing some opposite field
pop
could be 11 of 12 he can get schwarber
with two down 2-2 pitch here it is
and he got him looking and schwarber
knew it so meryl kelly gets his third
strike fourth strike out of the night
and he sits aside down in order for the
second straight inning
kelly ready to go he winds and fires
harrison hits a long drive to left this
one's got a chance way back toward the
wall goes young he leaps and it's gone
josh harrison gets into one for his
first homer of the year
and this is now a 10-5 game as the nats
are a run closer a base hit here really
makes things interesting 21 career
homers right-handed for bell
right he hits it hard right at the
center fielder back to tag
and jordy mercer had to hustle back to
the third base bag it's now 10-6
slam range
shipped his on the left side against
cirrus in the pitch to it
and he goes the other way to right
haven smith under it in right field
makes a catch
shot of the warning track that'll in the
image so they settle for the one run
oh that's a good pitch
edwin moscosso the young home plate on
par took a second
trying to give it a 10-6 game
he goes
instead of the belt the pitch
swing and a fly ball hit pretty well to
right
and this one is going to go a home run
for pavon smith
for the diamondbacks another home run
their fourth of the night they get a run
back to make it 11-6
one swing of the bat how nice is that
then you can get a run back no doubt
about that one either that ball was
crushed
is
curious
who gave up a home run
and turner's a strikeout victim one out
in the ninth inning
[Music]
another strikeout
two down in the nine this is the
center-cut sinker right there that's a
swing josh bell will not want to put on
his highlight reel
popped him up
into the wind ahmed wants it
and the diamondbacks open up a four-game
set in d.c a 10-game road trip with a
big 11-6 win